they've been described as Hornets from
hell and with good reason the giant
Asian Hornet is about the size of a
matchbox
it's stinking penetrated beekeeper suit
and they kill around 50 people a year in
Japan in December the Washington State
Department of Agriculture verified two
sightings of the Hornet reports of
honeybee colonies being destroyed soon
followed they're one of the largest
Hornets that we have on the planet
and so that's what makes them so unusual
and it makes them so striking to people
if they do not occur here it's thought
the Hornets were either deliberately
released or arrived as stowaways on
international cargo they become active
in the spring and scientists say just 15
of these Giants can destroy an entire
colony of 30,000 bees in hours their
habit of devouring native honeybees is
now a real concern our biggest fear is
that it will actually impact small
beekeepers and maybe drive them out of
business and raise costs for larger
beekeepers it's just something we don't
want to see happen
plans are now in place to begin trapping
and killing the Hornets before they
established themselves as a dangerous
invasive species for years now bees have
been dying at record rates impacted by
climate change disease and pesticides
the agricultural industry has already
been fighting a battle to keep healthy
colonies alive now there's a new threat
according to the Department of
Agriculture one in every three mouthfuls
of food is in some way a product of bee
pollination crops like apples
blueberries and cherries all rely on
these scientists say this new threat
needs to be tackled before it's too late
pollination is a huge part of
agriculture and the agricultural systems
we have here in the United States and so
if this were to become well-established
and then starts spreading it could be
pretty catastrophic members of the
public are being warned not to approach
the Hornets if they see them for now
they're confined to the remote northwest
of the United States stopping them
spreading further is now a priority and
a gallica al Jazeera